donald trump is back my friend check
this out oh god from fox news trump
mocks comparisons of biden to jimmy
carter the current president is worse
yep this is actually really good trump
won't stop emailing me
i don't know about you guys he loves you
from him i got like four emails from
trump yesterday you got to sign up for
this
i'm like trump what are you doing and
one of them was like i went golfing
today and i was like that's fantastic i
don't want i don't need this but i sent
an email and he was like
he basically said stop comparing biden
to jimmy carter
he said well jimmy carter failed in the
face of many crises
joe biden is making the crises and i'm
like it's not wrong
it's actually a good it's actually a
good point uh
joe biden's policies are are resulting
in a lot of these things let me let me
show you
some of this what he said quote i see
that everybody is comparing joe biden to
jimmy carter
it would seem to me that is very unfair
to jimmy carter
jimmy mishandled crisis after crisis but
biden has created christ after crisis
first there was the biden border crisis
that he refuses to call crisis
then the economic crisis then the biden
israel crisis another abiding gas crisis
and those are all policies those are all
the positions of the obama
administration
joe biden has had the worst start of any
president in u.s history
and someday they will compare future
disasters to the baby administration but
no
jimmy was better he added republicans
have said the crisis of the border is a
direct result of biden's reversal of
trump air migration policies
the biden admin has in turn so the
problem is rooted in trump's strict
immigration policies
and human rights abuses you know what's
funny about that
trump's not president anymore the buck
stops with you
when bad things were happening with war
people were like yo but
trump inherited those wars and i was
like trump's president
the buck stops at the president i'm not
gonna pretend you know
i get it obama inherited the war from
bush obama still did messed up stuff
trump inherited the war from from obama
trump didn't create more worse
trump withdrawal out of the troops those
are good things trump still did some
messed up stuff
eight-year-old american girls killed in
a commando rate almost immediately when
trump got elected
but man now that they're playing this
game where
when trump got in and the economy was
booming 2019 best numbers of our lives
they're like no no it's not trump it's
not trump obama created this economy
and now the economy is really bad it's
trump's fault well i think the economy
was in a bubble
when trump came in there was just a mass
printing raid
since 2008 really we've just seen the
money increase increasing
it was the last year of trump where
really before before it exploded and now
well now it's just it's still expanding
it's just bubbling super fast
unemployment was very low gdp was very
high stock market was very high
uh people had jobs low end wages were
going up and this was 2019 this was
before cover this was before the
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars it was long enough into trump's
presidency
that you couldn't give all the credit to
obama it was three years in
it was clear that trump crafted an
economy that worked for the market
and worked for the lowest wage earners
in america
but trump mishandled kovid the crisis
politically he didn't mishandle it in
terms of the general approach to how you
would how you would handle the
the pandemic simply because we don't
have a control country by which we could
measure
what would have been good or bad it was
a not novel virus
trump took action i thought it was good
but politically democrats
were and republicans were all printing
money like crazy democrats and
republicans are the ones who created
this unemployment stimulus thing
and you had some like thomas i think it
was thomas massey right who was like
don't give people money not to work oh
yeah but republicans and democrats where
was trump
trump was very supportive of a lot of
the stuff trump was very much like print
more money give the people more money
yeah
and now the bill comes due however i'm
not going to fault trump
for a pandemic and an emergency
the problem is what was happening was
across the board
democrats and republicans trump
everybody was like i don't know what
we're doing the governors were like
cuomo was like maybe i'd just kill 15
000 people and
so trump could have done politically a
lot better and the reason i say this
trump should have fired a lot of people
he shouldn't have fired some people
he should have been stricter with some
people and so i feel like when the
pandemic hit
and you saw the violation of
constitutional rights trump could have
the federal government could have
intervened but trump didn't do a lot of
these things
he didn't shut down the riots the riots
are still happening right
so a lot of the stuff we are seeing are
uh i should say
some of it does come from from trump
however
joe budden has been president now for
just about four months he has enacted
tons of policies
and the and the major problems we're
seeing are direct result of democrat
pushes some with republicans but
the the border policies the conflict in
the middle east
economic crisis gas shortages where's
the fbi been
why why wh this cyber attack on colonial
fbi is too busy tracking down grandmas
who took a tour through the capitol on
the wrong day that is biden's
administration who was prioritizing
going after
bumbling dotards who walked in and i
mean it look i get it the people who
stormed in were like bashing cops
yes arrest those people but they're
actually going after like they got one
guy and it's like the door was open he
was confused and he walked and they're
like and now you go to prison
that's what they're focusing on and our
gas pipelines are being just shut down
great great thanks thanks guys i
appreciate it as if this gas
uh pipeline shutdown is going to be an
isolated event
no i expect the worst hope for the best
expect the worst if you want to survive
it is it is a
it is a plausible promise that has been
confirmed that will feed
a decentralized open source uh activity
in this manner
that it's clear now that you can
independently attack a uh would you say
what i'm saying independently attack uh
a pipeline shut it down cause this kind
of disruption it's going to inspire
other people to do this
yesterday they said people were drilling
into the pipeline
eco terrorists were going up to the
pipelines like drilling a hole in it
somewhere along the champions like there
was speculation about that oh
yeah i don't know for sure i was
jokingly whispering bitcoin
that's that's the joke i didn't say buy
bitcoin i just had bitcoin
not giving any financial advice to but
that's bitcoin backwards that's
really hard weird stuff with that yeah
because i don't think firstly i don't
think it's biden's fault that's been
going on for a hundred years almost
no it is sad and terrifying did you guys
see the video of the rockets
flying into town an iron dome yeah
yeah it's it's it's uh uh i i don't
wanna i don't wanna pretend like biden
takes full responsibility for a
conflict that's been going on for a long
time but a lack of leadership
first we can just say biden does not
have the mental ability
to lead at a crisis right now for what's
going on
more importantly you can look to people
like ben shapiro who point out that joe
biden started funding a bunch of these
palestinian groups and then all of a
sudden we get a
missile barrage a few months in oh i
think the idea here is that trump was
very clear in his support for israel it
was very clear they were working hard to
secure israel and it was very clear that
they were going to support israel in
doing anything that they had to do to
defend themselves
and now that he is gone there is
weakness in the white house
at best at worst there is a collaborator
in the white house uh you know if you're
from the israeli perspective
and so they have now been inspired to
begin hostilities again because the uh
sort of the threat matrix is is out of
uh balance where it was in balance when
trump was there
and i i you know look i understand
there's a big conflict
i understand people are like you know
what you're talking about as soon as you
criticize anything
when i watch videos of rocket fires
which are random and are hitting buses
in schools
civilian targets and then israel does
surgical strikes on select targets
which sometimes is civilian targets
because hamas
and you know these groups are using them
it's a big difference
i understand and and i hear from the the
left of the pro-palestinian side saying
you know they've right to defend
themselves and i'm like i don't know if
that extends to like blowing up a school
and they say the same thing about israel
i'm like maybe you need to stop the
people from going into schools and using
them as missile bases i don't know i
don't know
you know but i'll put it this way okay
all right i'll step back
i don't know the depth of this
conference a lot of people much better
verse
than i it goes back to like the crusades
i mean it was like a port a trade port
yeah
1000 a.d probably even before that but
it you know now there's the suez canal
so it kind of protects that the canal
which is the
shipping line of the world basically
it's biden's fault man look
the end of the trump administration was
the abraham accords and you had a bunch
of arab nations
signing peace peace deals with israel
and that was huge and there was a lot of
speculation
that this would put pressure on these
extremist groups that are firing rockets
into israel to stop
because once they do things can start to
normalize that was the hope i suppose
but there's a lot of people who are like
it doesn't matter because israel is
settler colonialism and they should be
you know removed or whatever and so i
actually see these memes from any of
these leftists saying
israel should be removed outright
because they're colonists and
they're straight up saying the people in
israel shouldn't get say in it at all
and i'm like
come on i understand it's a conflict i
understand you think your side is right
but how do we resolve this by saying one
side must be purged from the land that's
insane
it can't be you could go if i could go
back 150 years and say maybe we should
build israel in a different place
because they were originally going to do
it in northeast africa
and then i think it was the balfour
declaration they said they were gonna
well basically what happened was world
war one
the arabs were on the side of the
ottomans and well i i look i got i'm
sorry
we'll check this out i understand but i
don't want to re i don't want to get
into
this i don't think anyone here has
enough knowledge on the israel
palestinian conflict is a little bit the
issue is joe biden
and his ability to lead and the middle
east and foreign policy not the history
of israel and why one side is right one
side is wrong
my point is i don't think i don't think
that removing one side is the way i
agree with you it's what it is there's a
bunch of people living there now
and so i don't know what the solution is
i can tell you that under trump
he seemed to be getting a hold on a lot
of the conflict in the middle east and
they hated him for it you know why
well in my opinion the
military-industrial complex types these
big weapons manufacturers
and the neocons which are now the
democrats
needed conflict in the middle east to
justify
expansion and occupation not in israel
in afghanistan iraq they want to go
after iran john bolton was like we're
going to celebrate next year in tehran
and everyone's like yay
and that was trump who brought that guy
in they want that but how do you justify
occupation in the middle east when
there's peace well
that was bad trump bringing peace to
these countries oh no
now how we gonna sell the american
people that we got to send more weapons
it wasn't
it wasn't peace in the west bank when he
the the israelis signed declarations of
uae
and remember when donald trump said they
were going to move the embassy to
jerusalem and they were like it's going
to be the end it's going to be
right nothing happened because the
palestinians are like jerusalem as our
holy city so to move
the the israeli american embassy to the
the jewish
the israeli version the point is
insulting i don't know
the the democrats are the neocons
yeah the neocons moved to the democratic
party now we got what's the story 100
republicans are like we're going to quit
the gop because of trump it's like okay
go
go join the democrats and be pro-war
please do seriously
yeah seriously and they uh they want war
joe biden wants war like we get news
reports as soon as joe biden's in that
movement into syria soldiers are moving
through
you know northeastern syria and i think
they want the conflict
and i think what's happening with israel
is good for them because they can
justify
why we should have war in the middle
east and it's it's
it's for a lot of reasons it's for
energy expansion it's for control of the
region
but you need the american people to
support it so this conflict between
israel and palestine is great for
democrats
joe biden what did he come out and say
just recently israel has a right to
defend itself
yeah it's weird because if you now we're
going to send more money to them our
ally
and we're going to have more conflict
which allows us to say we got to send
more missiles over there and occupy the
area
if you stick a person in a barricade
with 100 hungry bears and then you're
like
that human needs to defend himself well
like yeah you didn't need to put him in
the bear cage but you did
and you're right if you want him to
survive he needs to defend himself
that's kind of the situation of israel
right now well i'm just saying that
the conflict is good for those who want
to sell weapons
exactly and and have us energy right
energy dependent on another region
that's right that's right right so like
the keystone
shutdown not really aggressively
defending this uh pipeline attack
possibly shutting down another uh
pipeline in michigan
all these things are disrupting our
energy supplies we need oil where can we
get it we don't have it here
so i guess we got to go get it in we
could try blowing up kids in the middle
east
i hear that's a policy so wait a second
we can sell missiles
blow up kids and get expensive money
perfect
i'm in and donald trump is like
americans should have jobs
right and the democrats are like can we
blow up kids
now here's one of the problems with
trump is that first of all why
why bolton you know who gave him that
advice that was the stupidest thing it's
like i'm gonna hire this [ __ ]
because he saw him on tv a lot yeah
that's not a joke yeah yep
uh fox news and the other problem is
when he was pressured into the military
actions he was pressured into
that was he just i look trump is an
arrogant
guy he's full of himself he knows what
he wants but when it came to things he
wasn't an expert on he deferred to
people who are stupid
and then he was like i guess i'll fire
missiles and the news media loved it
they were like trump is presidential now
bombing children you know i remember
that day very vividly because i also
then went down to the white house to
cover
a alt-right richard spencer jason
kessler-led protest
against trump that day because of the
syrian missile strikes and then antifa
showed up i was i ended up in the middle
between these two
parties fighting i'm standing there
taking pictures
someone else took a picture of me taking
pictures of of uh
spencer and kessler and then posted that
later saying claiming that was that i
was a nazi
yeah yeah yeah but i remember that very
clearly but also trump deferred
on covet as well that's right and and
yet
you know the media of course the fouchy
they weren't really pleased about that
but i thought actually
in that case that he deferred to the
experts as well as anybody could have
deferred to the federalist system
deferred to the
state he shouldn't have when it came to
the
quote-unquote experts doctor what are
you going to do what are you going to do
you don't know anything about this and
you've got a guy that everybody's saying
fire them all and then what find other
experts yep
i mean it sounds i would it sounds that
easy dude no
i i understand it's not as easy
especially when they were obstructing
they wouldn't confirm a lot of his
cabinet position
the p you know they wouldn't confirm a
lot of people for his cabinet but
trump should have just went you know i
guess he thought he was going to win
another term
and so that was the goal play it
moderate or maybe he thought he was
helping the american people that was the
right thing no no
i mean like sure but he also why didn't
he just go and fire fauci why didn't he
send in the troops
re-election you you could only do so
much in your first or second term you
get more leeway because
this is it do what you got to do but
trump was aiming for the win i mean
he got 10 million more votes second time
around
but you know what i refer to the biden
voters as it was it was a political
drive-by
these people don't care about politics
at all the people i know who voted for
biden
they're gone they're posting pictures of
the bread they made they voted for this
guy
they come in and they're like donald
trump is the fastest and we gotta vote
for joe biden then they do
now they're gone they don't watch cnn
they don't watch msnbc anymore they're
gone
and i'm sitting here and we're sitting
here like well the world's on fire where
are they at now to take responsibility
for what they just did
none no responsibility and of course
when they'll filter it through their
their mental model of the world they
won't make any connection to any of
their behavior they're voting they're
supporting
these policies that leads to all these
terrible outcomes and now
we're all left here holding the bag and
hey but good news
there's just three years and eight
months left
yeah i hear trump is considering running
again four years from now
yeah is that how it works i i hate that
it is like a reality show this whole
political
circus where it's like um two years out
there's gonna be non-stop media coverage
about who's running for office again
like is that really what
what the human race cares about are you
kidding there's so much technology
and advancements that we can make on our
own because because rav and reality tv
the democrats want to burn the system to
the ground they want to extract what
they can while they can
and so they have very limited power
right now they have the senate by a
tiebreaker vote that's
it they have what like 11 seats in in
congress
and they don't have the supreme court
except by exertion of media pressure
and they have the president who is just
not all with it and they're like can we
just
squeeze the last little bit of you know
it's like you got extra virgin olive oil
this is like the opposite of that it's
like
you don't think that they're setting
themselves up in their mind you don't
think that they've thought that they've
won
the last contested election that the dem
the demographics are going to give them
the pre you know all the government for
forever
they're going to bring in 30 million new
voters and they're settling in
this is the new democratic way are you
do you think that if that were true joe
biden would have wouldn't have fired off
what he's like 50
60 or was it 53 memorandums and
executive orders
that was a panic that was him being like
oh just just
sign it sign it sign it sign it sign it
sign it before it's too late
yeah because the political drive-by the
people who can't that's why i'm saying
i don't think trump should run in 2024 i
think desantis should
yeah they'll smear desantis they'll
smear any republican who runs
but trump is a ball of fire that they
need
to trigger the the politically
uninitiated
desantis comes out could you imagine
someone going like their grandma and
being like this this santas guy's a nazi
she'll go
who but trump i know trump from the
apprentice
yeah he said all those nasty things oh
no they know who trump is
they came out they hated the guy
desantis are gonna be like i don't know
but that's so weird because everybody
loved trump until the day he
vote he decided to run for office oprah
jesse jackson
all those guys loved him pictures come
on my show put my arms around you i love
you donald trump's my boy
and he was too big and he and and you
know a lot of what he did helped him a
lot of what he did hurt him but it's
created this permanent ball of fire
if trump came back cnn would start
crying
praising the lord i thought we were
going to have to lay everyone off thank
god trump is back
if it's desantis they're gonna be like
desantis is bad
and people are gonna be like i don't
know who that is i don't care where are
they gonna they're gonna have to go
beyond hitler
right like mecca hitler desantis isn't
just hitler he's
trump he's trump
that's got to be the new highest level
smear right i guess
if you've already called someone hillary
look i'm i'm i'm not concerned right now
about where we're at in 2022 or 2024 no
it may be the case
that democrats are you know not you know
they're taking a little dirt hole to sit
in like a little chicken or something
they're going to get ready for their
dirt bath
you and your chickens that's right
they're getting really big in them early
right
what's up out there watching look you
look at the story with like liz cheney
and
the political world is completely
irrelevant right now when we're dealing
with all these crises
now i i shouldn't say completely
obviously
these things will have ramifications
moving forward into the political space
but what do people really care about
think about gotcha he's on your arm
stink bugged here we go don't throw them
at me
i eat it throw in bugs the chickens love
them they're like they just they
they fight over them oh yeah and they
they will pick them up and
pull them from each other's mouths
imagine being the stink bug and being
picked by chicken they're all just like
ripping your
limbs up thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you